541 on your monday morning we were
talking a couple of minutes ago about
jobs well there's a local business that
specializes
in personal defense and spy gadgets and
it's expanding
they've got things ranging from nanny
cams hidden safes
glasses that let you see what's behind
you well hector mejia is live near
decatur in lake mead to tell us
how that business has been growing
during the pandemic how does it work
hector
hey there nate good morning believe it
or not demand is actually up right now
during these times earlier we talked
about this pen that's actually a voice
recorder
now they have other gadgets like this
that allows you to check if there are
any hidden cameras in your home
uh when you do this anyway so we have a
lot of other items we have brett foxtrot
owner at cool cat spy
it's actually a cool cats buy gadgets
that rather yep
so good morning to you sir good morning
so this looks like an ordinary coin but
what is it
that is a concealer that actually can
hide quite a few different things with a
hidden message maybe you're a patent
lawyer maybe you're a writer
and that can hold micro sd cards inside
that and keep it safe
what are you seeing right now what are
people uh looking for during these times
uh just in general or just in general
yeah
yeah so uh people want to make sure that
they're secure
maybe they don't want to go as far as a
lethal weapon like a gun maybe they're
looking for a less lethal weapon to keep
them safe
or maybe they just want to make sure
that no one's breaking into their house
while they're gone and they're getting a
nanny cam
those are some of the two biggest things
that are going on right now what do we
have here we're gonna check if your
phone
yeah has a bug yeah so this is a really
awesome way to find out if your phone
has been tampered with
if there's like you said a bug on my
phone
now today we don't do physical bugs like
putting some kind of
uh device on it we use software
and that's going to override the
protocol of your normal phone
you were telling me earlier that
something as simple as an app
can really track you or or just bug your
phone in a way yes
yes so i can actually make it so i
change the device and mirror
all the information onto another device
so i can see everything that's going on
this is really dangerous it could be
your gps the camera could turn on
the microphone can turn on even while
it's on airplane mode if it's butt
exactly all right so we're gonna give
this a try so these look like some
pretty stylish
sunglasses but they're really not i can
see what's behind me i can see brett and
he is doing this
and he is doing this let's see
i'm not lying you can really see what's
behind you anyway we'll get some more
insight into uh how this business is
growing
not just here across the valley but how
it's coming up here to the northwest
part of town
in the next hour for now reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now back to you guys